un passe-montagne pour Kylian Mbappé et
un masque pour achra fakemi après avoir
assisté à un match de NBA les deux
joueurs du PSG ont tenté de passer
inaperçu lors d'une balade à New York
tentez car certains les ont reconnus là
en train d'assister à un spectacle de
rue à Times Square avant de revenir en
France les amis ont pris un selfie
devant un gratte-ciel avec un logo H&M
pas parce qu'ils sont de fidèles clients
juste pour les initiales Akimi Mbappé et
donc pour ce balader comme ça ils ont
mis la capuche et le bonnet
effectivement pour passer inaperçu on
n'a pas besoin
Paris Saint-Germain hier matin le club
lui a fait une belle surprise puisqu'il
a le droit à son arrivée et bien à une
haie d'honneur de tout le staff du
centre d'entraînement
[Musique]
c'est une photo historique la plus likée
sur Instagram avec 74 millions de j'aime
et pourtant elle est fausse en partie
car Lionel Messi brandit un faux trophée
sur ces images de la victoire de
l'Argentine en Coupe du Monde l'histoire
est révélé par un média argentins cette
réplique a été apportée dans le stade
par deux supporters de l'albie Céleste
qui ont réussi à la faire circuler sur
la pelouse en même temps que l'original
mais ce n'était même pas au courant
quand il la soulève il sait même pas que
c'est une réplique on se dit Maria qui
lui dit après non c'est pas la bonne
même toi même même toi même toi même
taille 75 millions de like c'est pas
prêt de nous arriver
alors ce qui est très important les gars
c'est un personnage très intéressant qui
est dans cette vidéo il s'agit du frère
de Kylian Mbappe regardez la photo juste
ici donc déjà il a absolument la même
tête que lui sauf qu'il a un petit peu
plus de cheveux et d'après l'expression
de son visage on a quand même
l'impression qu'il est pas très content
[Musique]
un désarme c'est l'un des livres les
plus attendus au Royaume-Uni en ce début
d'année l'autobiographie du prince Harry
sort mardi prochain les meilleurs
extraits ont déjà fuité dans la presse
et notamment le récit d'une violente
dispute en 2019 entre William et Harry
les deux frères en ce rêve venus aux
mains le prince Harry accuse son frère
William de l'avoir jeté au sol lors
d'une dispute autour du caractère de
Mégane Markle je ne connais pas une
seule famille où il y a pas eu des
Bizzbee voir des des prises de main
entre frères et sœurs et oui mais c'est
princesse normalement quand ils font
caca ça sent bon tu comprends bah non
mais c'est là où tu te trompes
quand les princes font caca ça sent pas
bon Harry révèle avoir tué 25 talibans
lorsqu'il était de soldats britannique
engagés il écrit avoir du considérer ses
cibles comme des pièces de jeu d'échec
pour pouvoir tirer le précise n'avoir
tué que des talibans aussi je voulais
rentrer en Grande-Bretagne entier mais
plus encore je voulais rentrer chez moi
avec ma conscience intacte ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas de violence qu'est-ce qui se passe
salut Siri bonsoir à tous on vit quand
même une époque
extraordinairement méchante mais
extraordinairement méchante d'abord il y
a quantité de cinglés manifestement des
Assas qui arrivent au pouvoir par la
voix des
urnes quantité de pays ce qui est très
inquiétant je viens de chanter
je demande à quoi je sers je viens oui à
rien je sais depuis longtemps je viens
te chanter la balade ah la balade des
gens heureux à moins qu'il y ait un
piège car il y a également la balade de
des vieux grincheux ensuite nous passons
notre temps via
nos téléphones portables à dénoncé via
les réseaux à dénoncer sans arrêt ils
sont en embrouille Mélenchon lui parce
que je comprends il y a un délire je
vois l'émission depuis tout à l'heure
oui
dit non c'est pas la question vous y
revenez
qu'on la règle on la règle maintenant
je souhaite être le premier youtubeur de
France d'ici 2026 et je souhaite rendre
la France la plus le pays de violence
pas de violence
et j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi mon
Cyril
[Rires]
trois heures 26 c'est le temps que nous
passons en moyenne devant la télévision
alors ça a l'air énorme comme ça mais
c'est 20 non c'est 15 minutes de moins
que l'année dernière une désinfection
Rémy qui touche notamment les
adolescents la télé n'est pas à la fête
en ce moment est mondial exemple d'abord
avec la France si TF1 reste la première
chaîne de France et même d'Europe elle a
enregistré en 2022 ça plus faible par
d’audience depuis sa création en 1975
parce que Manu ce matin tu pourras
l'engueuler manie du 6-10 il m'a dit
Manu du City
bah en fait c'est mon défi parce que
franchement
je je lève la barre j'avoue oh non parce
que alors tu vois parce que tu as failli
faire défoncer
même tendance aux États-Unis ou les
plateformes de streaming vidéo sont en
train de remporter la partie
l'hémorragie des abonnés au bouquet de
chaînes de la télévision payante là-bas
se poursuit un rythme soutenu désormais
seul 55 % des foyers américains sont
abonnés à la télévision payante
traditionnelle contre 85 % il y a encore
10 ans dans un instant nos invités du
dîner Faustine Bollaert
Daniel Pennac le vu l'oeil de pierre et
les actualités de